endlich ist es soweit es gibt ein neues
kilogramm das als einzelkinder aus einer
platin iridium regierung in einem tresor
in paris hat nämlich ausgedient und ein
neues gibt es auch nicht wie bitte
die wissenschaft hat eine andere lösung
gefunden und die hat gerade noch so eine
riesige katastrophe in der größe eines
samt kurz verließ um science fiction die
gibt's täglich faszinierend des seins
velos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
das war wirklich eine absolute
katastrophe als wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zwischen 1988 und 1992
eine rätselhafte veränderung amour
kilogramm fest stellten damals gab es
die zweite nach prüfung des kilogramms
das 1889 je gestellt worden war
und es war kein kilogramm mehr es war
leichter geworden und zwar ziemlich
genau 000 05 gramm so schwer wie ein
sandkorn nicht viel für den laien aber
für die wissenschaft eine katastrophe
dabei waren kopien dieses uhr kilos
nicht leichter geworden war das
französische original zu oft geputzt
worden noch heute rätselt die
wissenschaft denn eigentlich sorgt das
iridium für hohe abriebfestigkeit nur
eines waren nach dieser feststellung
klar es musste etwas neues her
und das konnte kein metall trotz seien
viel zu ungenau einfach das kilogramm
war die einzige einheit die nicht durch
eine naturkonstante ermittelt werden
konnte ein meter ist zum beispiel die
strecke die licht in einer bestimmten
zeit zurücklegt da die
lichtgeschwindigkeit unabänderlich ist
ist damit auch ein meter exakt definiert
und jetzt gilt das auch für das
kilogramm jetzt definiert sich das
kilogramm aus der plan konstante und wie
das geht erklärt finn von brings ganz
genau
mit hilfe einer waage am national
institute of standards and technology
hat man die plan konstante h ermittelt
um damit das kilogramm neu zu definieren
das funktioniert in zwei phasen die
gewichts- und die geschwindigkeit phase
auf beiden seiten der waage findet man
jeweils zwei feste dauermagneten an
jedem bewegt waren arm der waage hängt
eine spule mit aufgewickelt im draht die
sich jeweils zwischen den magneten
bewegen kann verbunden sind beide seiten
über ein rad in der gewichts phase steht
auf einer seite ein kilogramm prototyp
auf einer schale und rückt nach unten
parallel wird strom durch die schule
geführt wodurch ein elektromagnet
erzeugt wird die eine magnetische kraft
nach oben ausübt
ziel dieser methode ist es durch
variierende stromstärken die nach oben
wirkende magnetische kraft und die nach
unten wirkende gewichtskraft
gleichzusetzen
am ende soll die masse m herauskommen
erdbeschleunigung g und stromstärke
kennen wir aber die feldstärke b und die
draht länge elde spule lässt sich nicht
so genau messen
deswegen wird in der geschwindigkeit
phase ohne gewicht ein elektromotor auf
der anderen seite genutzt um die spule
mit einer gleichmäßigen geschwindigkeit
hoch und runter durch das magnetische
feld zu bewegen durch diese bewegung
entsteht dann eine induktion die eine
messbare spannung erzeugt und sich außer
magnetischen feldstärke b
der draht länge l und der
geschwindigkeit frau berechnet
durch geschicktes umständen können wir
die formel daher gleichstellen nice
aspekt beide seiten entsprechen nun der
einheit war deswegen auch wattwagen
durch einsetzende immer wieder
gemessenen werte sollten wir auf ein
kilogramm kommen diese gemessenen werte
und die masse können wir in die formel
zur berechnung der planck konstante
einsetzen die bisherige plan konstante
wurde so ab den zwanzigsten mai 2009 10
durch einen neuen wert ersetzt woraus
dann immer die masse eines kilogramms
hergeleitet werden kann mit diesem
verfahren wurde jetzt also die planck
konstante exakt definieren bis dato war
man sich nicht so ganz sicher welchen
wert sie genau hatte spricht sie wurde
von einem exakten kilogramm abgeleitet
das wird jetzt durch eine silizium kugel
mit einer ganz exakten menge an silizium
28 atom bestimmt allerdings wird eine
solche kugel durch die definition der
plan konstanten jetzt nicht mehr zum
bestimmen eines kilogramms benötigt
durch die definition der plan konstante
kann jetzt mittels einer waage überall
ganz exakt gewogen werden ohne sie wäre
es zu einer katastrophe in der
wissenschaft gekommen
denn vom
programm hängen auch zahlreiche andere
einheiten ab sie alle wären mehr oder
weniger falsch geworden und damit die
physik zu einer ungenauen wissenschaften
hurra ja das kommt jetzt gott sei dank
verhindert werden neudefinition
kilogramm ein video ihr drauf krieg mit
noch mehr informationen zum thema von
bei trinks also anklicken anschauen und
natürlich bei zwings abonnieren hammer
kanal mit videos anklicken anschauen ich
habe schon gesagt aber trotzdem nochmal
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran